mais au delà de l'acteur au délà du
comédien de l'année artiste ou d'un de
l'icône moi ce qui me plaît ce qui me
plaît encore plus et quand une icône
elle reste proche des gens quant à la
une dimension humaine et belmondo tu
sentais qu'ils se forçait pas ils
étaient là les anecdotes de jeff il est
dans votre sens il était sans fard et
sans prén nation est d'ailleurs son fils
paul disait tout à l'heure mon père il
aimait les militaires il aimait les
flics il aimait les voyous ça dit
beaucoup de choses ça ça veut dire qu'il
ne jugeait pas les gens d'ailleurs il a
fait découvrir qui prime et avant tout
c'était l'homme qui avait derrière
l'uniforme ou le personnage et même son
petit fils victor quand il a pris la
parole à l'hommage national moi j'étais
très touché il a parlé de son grand-père
et d'ailleurs du jardin l'a fait ensuite
tel un soleil indien est un soleil mon
grand-père qui irradié
tout le monde et tout le temps et il a
dit à la fin tu resteras un soleil
éternel et du jardin à la fin lorsqu'il
a été interrogé il a dit jean-paul
c'était un soleil mais c'était un soleil
qui qui rejaillissait sur les autres il
donnait beaucoup et cette générosité
dans une société telle que la nôtre
anxiogène fracture et
d'entretien belmondo qui est généreux
qui est authentique qui est simple alors
que c'est une icône qui est accessible
il y en ad'autres de stars il y en a une
autre d'icônes qui était pas le manche
nationale et qui a dû être très très
triste très touché c'est alain delon et
quand tu fais le comparatif entre les
deux en termes du coin en termes de
starisation je pense qu'ils sont
quasiment les niveaux y en a un
qui est peut-être un peu plus dans le
coeur des français que l'autre c'est sûr
non non ceci les taxis c'est pas la même
relation si jeune à la même relation
c'est parce qu'il est accessible parce
qu'il est simple parce qu'il avait une
gouaille parce qu'il avait une gueule et
tout ça était vrai et d'ailleurs là
aussi paul son fils moi j'étais très
touché par sa famille plein d'humilité
plein de simplicité à l'image du père on
a une éducation au centre des valeurs
ont fait pas semblant chebel mundo il a
dit son fils paul mon père c'est en gros
c'est l'incarnation de la vérité mais
franchement mais mais ça paris des mots
simples mais dans la société
d'aujourd'hui être vrai être accessible
à très simple être fédérateur alors que
on voit bien que on a plutôt tendance
aujourd'hui à diviser a fracturé a
opposé
c'est un type qui incarne une france
qu'on aime moi c'est facile c'est la
france de mon enfance moi je j'ai deux
ans deux de plus que yann même si on
dirait qu'il en a cinq de plus mais
heureusement on est pendus à couper à
trouver la vérité de la vérité mais
soirées comme ça dommage pour convaincre
que quelqu'un barras a
encouragé le rappelle que je t'aime donc
tu as un bon acteur mais les dialogues
la vérité c'est que on peut honnêtement
si las il a bercé notre enfance est
bercée autrement il a pas versé que
notre pas pourquoi on est une icône
aussi parce qu'on a traversé les
décennies les années 60 dans soixante
dix années 80 les années 90 des années
2000 des wings n'a pas comparu géniale
idée oui mais c'est aussi par rapport à
de longs qui s'est construit il a eu
besoin de longs de long fait toujours la
gueule belmondo sourit tout le temps
mais l'un et l'autre ont eu besoin comme
deux titans je considère que ces deux
génies à égalité ils se sont construits
l'un sur l'autre l'un avec l'autre et
cette compétition leur a permis de
trouver aussi leurs personnages et leur
place dans le renouvellement de dos et
de niro pacino
c2c à ce niveau là